كيف تتخوف من بطء الهجوم المضاد وتقول انه
دون الامداد الغربي الكامل ستكون الخطط
العسكريه غير مجديه على الاطلاق تصريحات
قد تكون مفاجئه للغرب لا سيما وان النيتو
والاتحاد الاوروبي لم يوفر دعما بالمال او
السلاح في العاشر من حزيران يونيو اعلن
الرئيس الاوكراني فولو دوميرزيلنسكي ان
الهجوم المضاد قد بدا بالفعل قبل هذا
التاريخ مباشره وعلى مدى اشهر ارسلت
الولايات المتحده ناقلات جند من طراز
برادلي الى كييف والتي تسهل نقل الجنود
بشكل اسرع وتقدم حمايه افضل من غيرها في
الميدان وزودت عده دول الجيش الاوكرانيه
بدبابات
التي تعتبر ابرز اسلحه النيتو والتي كررت
اوكرانيا دوما انها اساسيه في اي هجوم
مضاد كما بعثت بريطانيا بدبابات تشالنجر
اثنان
على مستوى الصواريخ الهجوميه والدفاعيه
تبقى بيتريوت الامريكيه المنظومه الابرز
والتي تنجح في اعتراض صواريخ مثل كنجال
الروسيه صحيفه واشنطن بوست قالت في تقرير
لها ان الاسلحه المتطوره قد ترجح الكفه
لصالح اوكرانيا ويضيف التقرير ان واشنطن
والحلفاء ركزوا على تعزيز قدره اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه والمعدات الغربيه قبيل انطلاق
الهجوم اضافه لتدريب الاوكرانيين على
استخدام الاسلحه لاختبار فاعليتها
الميدانيه تضيف الصحيفه انه لكي تنجح
اوكرانيا في عمليات الهجوم المضاد
والاستيلاء بسرعه على الاراضي زودت واشنطن
كييف باسلحه مختلفه ومع الاخذ بالاعتبار
تاريخ اعلان زيلنس انطلاق الهجوم المضاد
اعلنت واشنطن في اليوم عينه تخصيص مليارين
ومئه مليون دولار تشمل معدات للدفاع الجوي
وذخائر وصوا موجهه اتبعتها بمساعدات بقيمه
500 مليون دولار منتصف حزيران يونيو بينما
خصص الاتحاد الاوروبي قبيل الهجوم بثلاثه
اسابيع مساعدات عسكريه بقيمه مليار ونصف
مليار دولار من مجمل 18 مليار دولار
سيقدمها بحلول نهايه العام الحالي
وتتصدر الولايات المتحده قائمه المانحين
بنحو 80 مليار دولار يليها الاتحاد
الاوروبي بنحو ثمانيه وثلاثين مليار دولار
ثم بريطانيا بحوالي تسعه مليارات دولار
وبولندا بمبلغ قارب اربعه مليارات دولار
وفقت المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا في عام واحد تكلفه تسع سنوات من
حرب افغانستان وفي وقت تكرر كييف طلب
طائرات اف 16 لا تبدو ان الامور على
الجبهه تسير وف النقطه الاوكرانيه حقق
الجيش الاوكراني بعض المكاسب الميدانيه
عند خطوط القتال لكنه لم يصل لمرحله تحقيق
خرق استراتيجي على اي من الجبهات وسائل
اعلام امريكيه كانت قد نقلت قبل عام انه
في اتصال هاتفي
تقديم حزمه من المساعدات بقيمه مليار
دولار عجلات نظيره الامريكي بلائحه اضافيه
من الطلبات خطوه افقدت بيض اعصابه ودفعته
لتفكير زيلنسكي بسخاء دافع الضرائب
والاداره الامريكيه داعيا الرئيس
الاوكراني لابداء بعض الامتنان
[موسيقى]